it's been a strange 48 hours in the
world of AI with releases like udio that
have reminded millions of people what AI
is capable of and models that can pay
you infinite attention but we also got
befuddling updates from open AI that
suggests that not all is smooth sailing
I'll start of course with the new model
on audio.com and how musicians are
reacting then cover the perplexing
manner of the release of gp4 Turbo with
vision and touch on a fascinating new
infinite context paper from Google but
now let's hear three 20 second extracts
from udio to give you an inkling if you
haven't heard it already of what it's
capable of here's June the Broadway
musical TR of the greatest leader we've
ever seen they say that he's a listen
out
guy eyes bright blue and hair black you
should see him ride on a sand worm's
back up to Victory
useful and now for some quite frankly
amazing AI generated classical
[Music]
music and next something I'm going to
bleep a little bit but represents the
reaction
of Uncharted Labs who are behind udio to
their servers going
down getting huged but the
is the is
down we appreciate you and we want your
sign ups but the side is
[Music]
down and of course I have been playing
about with udio like almost everyone has
and did you know it can do standup
comedy and even Brits say hello
yeah we're talking Posh don't baffle you
and have a cup of tea it's odd to hear
AI talk right now I'm not sure if this
guy's talking about me but I thought I'd
let you know that this kind of thing is
possible and how about a quick direct
comparison between udio Ando
V3
missar from open
AI he's gone so
far
together missing
star from
openi now I prefer video there but you
do sometimes get complete
the I sick you a CRI R he coming down
and whs her you
got now will I am calls udio the best
tech on Earth and Uncharted Labs which
is the company behind udio he says is
really aiming to be an ally for
creatives and artists now it should of
course be noted that Will I Am is an
investor in udio but again they repeat
that udio is about building AI tools to
enable the next generation of Music
creators now of course everyone has
their own opinion but let's now get a
taste of the reaction from some
musicians one says it's pretty scary
thinking what is going to exist a year
or two from now and what it means for
musicians listeners and the industry as
a whole the top comment says I would buy
a band t-shirt but never buy a shirt for
an AI which makes sense but here are two
more common reactions I'm a music
professional producer SL composer This
is highly Advanced and I thought this
stuff was years away and one more I've
already gone full circle with it past
the confusion and Devastation and now
I'm just curious what Gregorian chant
would sound like with I can't even
pronounce that and blast beats so
definitely a mixed reaction from
musicians personally I don't think it's
too much of an exaggeration to call this
the chat GPT moment moment for music
generation sunno often has a slight
tinniness that gives it away for those
not following AI but with udio I think
you could convince many people that
they're listening to Human music just
like chat felt like human text if you
didn't look too closely I could well see
before the end of this year hundreds of
millions of people using this for
entertainment imagine every school child
in the world walking out of their lesson
in whichever language with a catchy tune
about what learned so yes I do believe
that udio is the biggest news of this
week but of course we had the mysterious
release of a new gp4 turbo model from
open Ai and why do I call it mysterious
well not because it wasn't named GPT 4.5
they probably thought it wasn't enough
of a step forward to give it that name
the strangeness was the repeated
emphasis on it being better than
previous iterations but without any
detail they called it major improved
where are the benchmarks though and now
here's some more mystery all the top
players at open AI like Greg Brockman
and Miram murati tweeted out the news of
the new model but strangely for the
first time samman didn't now this isn't
about reading any tea leaves is just a
very strange announcement from open aai
I ran my own maths and logic benchmarks
and I couldn't see much of a difference
it failed the same questions that the
January version of gpc4 Turbo failed of
course the functionality improved with
function calling within Vision but what
intrigued me was the repeated claims
that gp4 reasoning had been further
improved naturally on this channel
that's what I was most focused about The
Cutting Edge of intelligence here though
is some of the best benchmarking work
that I could find on the noted math
benchmark from Dan hendris you could see
a bump in its performance on the hardest
style of questions from 35% to around
45% even one level down the performance
bumped up from 57% to 66% the difference
on the easier questions wasn't nearly as
pronounced it seems pretty clear that
the data set got augmented with some
highlevel mathematics and code otherwise
it wasn't too much changed here's
another example live codebench you can't
complain about contamination because
they Source their questions from after
the training day of the models and again
as you can see performance has increased
particularly for harder questions these
are sourced from contests like leak code
and that applies not just to code
generation but self-repair again though
we're not talking about massive leaps
just small bumps here though is the
clearest assessment from Epoch AI the
diamond set of the GP QA are the hardest
kind of graduate questions we're talking
Google proof stem questions that even
phds find hard and yes there was a bump
Maybe by 2 or 3% but gp4 turbo April
Edition is still lower performing than
Claude 3 Opus of course the deeper
question is whether or not this
indicates some inherent limitations on
just simply training on more and more
Advanced Data it's a bit like the
current Paradigm can only go so far even
with better data of course you can watch
any of my other videos to see why I
don't think that will be much of a
bottleneck that much longer now it would
be remissive me not to spend a few
seconds touching on two releases from
the open weights Community I'm not going
to call it the open source Community
because they're not releasing their
training data sets I'm talking about the
new mix trial 8times 22 billion mixture
of experts model and coher command r+
now you can judge for yourself but they
land around the level of Claude 3 Sonet
which is the mediumsized model of course
that is a proprietary model some people
may have expected the open weights
Community to have caught up to GPT 4 by
now but that's not quite the case of
course let's wait to see if llama 3 can
further bridge that Gap now before we
get to Google there was one more
announcement of a model I want to touch
on this time though as I've done once
before on this channel I reached out to
the company to ask about a sponsorship
I've probably turned down thousands of
sponsorship offers but I'm happy to say
that this part of the video is sponsored
by assembly AI so what happened they
released universal one and basically the
reason I reached out to them is because
it's really darn good I'm often
transcribing videos and rarely do they
get characters like GPT correct let
alone names like sassia nadela universal
one did so yes universal one is the
model I personally use and you can see
some comparisons to other models in this
chart it does seem to hallucinate less
than whisper and takes 38 seconds to
process an hour of audio anyway
Universal one only came out like a week
ago and I think it's epic but let me
know what you think the link of course
will be in the description but now from
yesterday a quite fascinating paper from
Google it's about Transformer models
that could have infinite context not 1
million or 10 million but infinite I
must say unusually for this channel I
haven't had a chance to finish the paper
before talking about it but I wanted to
include it in this video for a reason of
course the prospect of feeding in entire
libraries is fascinating but my theory
is that this approach might be behind
Gemini 1.5 long context ability if you
remember Gemini 1.5 whose API is now
widely available was able to process up
to at least 10 million tokens notice the
phrase at least there if you're not
familiar with tokens think 10 million
tokens is being around 8 million words
and if that's a daunting number think
eight entire sets of Harry Potter novels
now on the day that Gemini 1.5 came out
I called it the biggest development of
that day despite it being the same day
that Sora came out I would still stick
to that to this day Gemini 1.5 could
find metaphorical needles in videos 3
hours long or audio 22 hours long and
the performance just kept improving up
to and Beyond 10 million tokens but back
to yesterday's paper why do I think
there's any link now one hint is that
one of the authors manal fari and sorry
if I'm mispronouncing your name was also
an author in the original Gemini papers
and the other hint comes from the paper
itself where they call their approach a
plug andplay long context adaptation
capability with which they can
continually pre-train existing llms in
other words it appears like you can take
existing llms and just pre-train them
with this approach to make them great at
long context or indeed infinite context
is that part of what happened to Gemini
1 Pro to turn it into Gemini 1.5 Pro
anyway it is interesting that Google
published this while still being a bit
Cy about some crucial details they do
conclude though that this approach
enables llms to process infinitely long
contexts even though they've got bounded
memory and computation resources now I
am going to consult with some colleagues
before I say much more about this paper
but just think about some of the
possibilities imagine a model being able
to process every film made by a
particular director or every work of
French literature between a particular
period or every email that you've ever
sent since birth but let's not get too
far ahead of ourselves because it's not
like Google don't have their own issues
this week we learned that apparently
Demis cabis said that he thought it
would be especially difficult for Google
to catch up to its rival open AI with
generated video he also apparently mused
about leaving Google and raising
billions of dollars to start a new
research lab if he did leave to start
his own lab that would swiftly become a
very competitive lab to bring us back to
the start that's actually how yudo was
born we learned from the information
that yudo is the work of Uncharted Labs
made up primarily of former Google deep
mine staff those researchers had created
the model Lia back in this spring of
last year that could be a very similar
model to what we now have in udio but
the company didn't unveil it until
November of last year and Google still
hasn't made it available to the public
it seems like Demis aabis isn't the only
one with some frustration at Google but
before I end the video I must give
Google great credit for this release
within the last 24 hours with deep
learning of course they trained these
Ultra cute football players and yes I'm
calling it football these two players
weren't manually designed to do the
moves they're doing through deep
reinforcement learning they leared to
anticipate ball movements and block
opponent shots and these guys were
trained in simulation which I talked
about in my recent Nvidia video compared
to a prescripted baseline these agents
walked three times faster turned four
times faster and kicked the ball 30%
faster soon therefore we could have our
own mini earling Harland so quite the
roller coaster 48 hours in AI as always
let me know what you think in the
comments feel free to hop on board my
patreon but regardless thank you so much
for watching and have a wonderful day